all right Mark
oh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally Oregon
tell me about your family how did you
grow up
I don't know
if you remember your family at all no
my mom and dad are all dead
candy really well did
bill that is good
y'all go what I said they let me live
I and
I don't know how to live
you don't know how to live no
you're taking alcohol is your is your
drug I do that well
when did that start for you huh when did
that start for you
I don't remember you when did that when
did you start drinking at what age oh
when I was young
I had a little kid really
yeah six years ago
you think your parents were drinkers
yeah yeah
my mom and dad drank
you should drink Vodka
you got me sorry
I've been drinking ever since how old
are you now 60 60.
and you've been living homeless for a
while six years
how many years 60. your whole life yeah
well just I don't know what month it is
end of April
okay yeah April 3rd
maybe my date of birth
April 3rd is your birthday huh you said
April 3rd is your birthday yeah
so how do you survive now where do you
get money for your
I asked people to help me people well
pen head you'll Panhandle or people yeah
try
and what do you how much do you drink a
day typically
oh a couple drinks
wait what's the culture
I don't know what they are a little
giant plant
a vodka yeah
they use Legend beer
a beer too yeah
do you have children no no kids you ever
been married no ever been in love no
well yeah
I'm in love when I first growing up but
they didn't last very long yeah
you're drinking even when you were in
high school
yeah
did you ever have jobs
what kind of jobs did you have
uh I don't know I was doing a
four out of town I don't know where I'm
at
but I worked
I made money
had work
I take it you've not worked for a long
time not no more
yeah I'm crippled and broke
where do you where do you stay at do you
sleep
yeah where do you sleep at night
on the sidewalk
[Music]
I don't have blanket or nothing it's got
to be rough
I don't got nothing
[Music]
just a
depressing lifestyle for you what do you
get depressed living this kind of life
probably
not good
being alone and
being free do you have friends at all
no no friends
do you have any regrets in your life huh
do you have any regrets in your life no
if I do I don't know it
what are you afraid of now at 60 years
old
I'm done
you think you think you'll
your life will be over soon huh you
think your life will be over soon
you doubt it I don't
I can't hardly walk or nothing I fall
down a lot broke my head
end up in a hospital
and they throw me out
to me I can't do that
whatever
you see the scar on your huh I see the
scar on your eye yeah I got Stars what
what's that from
what what's that from
what what is the scar from
me falling down
[Music]
because my legs don't work
and then broke
I've pulled down a lot
full of my face
how drunk will you get it right how
drunk will you get
I don't know
you don't remember no
you like I drink every day a little bit
and then
good until
God spoke with me or character whoever
there
next with me but do you do do you black
out sometimes
I think so yeah
do you have any good memories of your
life what do you have any good memories
of your life
oh I don't think so
I can't think of it
you had your life to live all over again
would you have done anything differently
no
I haven't never have yeah have you ever
tried to stop drinking
it was boring
quit drinking and don't have no friends
I don't know
do you have any family sisters brothers
I did but I don't know where they're at
[Music]
yeah I got a sister and a brother
I might have a couple grand kids
Sons
or whatever they are
I don't know
you're an individual and independent
if you had bad things happen to you here
on the streets what have you had bad
things happen to you living on the
streets I don't know what you're saying
have you had bad things happen to you
have people beat you up robbed you done
things like that yeah
I'm pretty sure
Mark is there anything you've learned in
your life any lessons you've learned
uh
she has trouble
yeah stay out of trouble
that's been using in jail
prison
before
because I'm violent oh you get violent
oh yeah
I'm alcoholic when you drink you get it
you tend to get violent yeah
I'm left alone
until the cops see me
make them pull me over
until you can't do that
say okay fine
should I take my dinner away
and I think okay that's good
and then they arrest me
have you ever talked with a therapist or
anything like that no
I'm quiet
you'd rather just be left alone and
yeah you left alone and let let you
drink
and I dreamed by myself
just a little bit about you
usually I drink beer
[Music]
you're not really looking to change
anything huh you're not really looking
to change anything
I don't know nothing
I'm brain dead
all right Mark thank you so much for
sharing your story
you're welcome
wish you lots of luck out here you're
welcome
yeah I'm going to help you